[Musique]
oui bonjour Est-ce que je parle
chez moi est-ce que je parle
oui
[Musique]
c'est moi oui madame
oui
désolé pour déranger ce matin c'est que
on enquête sur un réseau de fraudeur qui
sont basés sur internet à Montréal puis
on a remarqué que vos informations
personnelles il circulent dans leur
salle de Chatou de ses fraudeurs là
est-ce que vous est-ce que vous étiez au
courant non pas du tout
pour comprendre le fonctionnement de ces
réseaux de fraudeurs nous avons infiltré
des salles de clavardage sur des
plateformes web cryptées où se
transigent librement des données
personnelles volées grâce au hameçonnage
une sorte d'un camp ou encore de vastes
bazar où se vendent des achettes
quotidiennement des informations
confidentielles de milliers de Canadiens
salut les gars ces textos frauduleux il
y en a énormément qui circulent mais on
a bien l'impression que ce n'est qu'une
partie du problème c'est beaucoup plus
large c'est un rouage central d'un vaste
écosystème que vous avez justement
pénétrer explorer par quoi commencer là
mais exact les textos frauduleux c'est
un peu la base de tout ça parce que ça
sert à me sonner des données
personnelles donc non nom de famille
adresse surtout informations de carte de
crédit mot de passe mais avec ces
données-là qui sont hameçonnés ça ouvre
tout un univers frauduleux finalement
parce que dans des salles de clavardage
cryptées sur des plateformes comme
telegram il y a des centaines souvent
même des milliers de personnes qui se
regroupent ensemble dans ces communautés
frauduleuses là et qui vont vendre ces
données-là nous avons pu communiquer
avec un fraudeur montréalais chevronné
qui accepté de répondre par courriel à
quelques-unes de nos questions
anciennement je vous dirais que mon
salaire par semaine était d'environ 5000
dollars beaucoup de jeunes de 16 ans
sont maintenant domaine j'ai déjà
rencontré des fraudeurs âgés de 13 14
ans il y a tellement de monde qui fait
de la fraude c'est impossible pour les
autorités de réussir à prendre tout le
monde mais on va se le dire la plupart
du temps le monde se remboursé donc ça
ne leur nuit qu'à court terme donc ça
peut être payant pour certaines
personnes mais pas tous parce que bien
sûr l'argent s'accumule assez rapidement
se dépense assez rapidement aussi puis
souvent les gens dans ces communautés là
veulent exhiber un certain mode de vie
un certain mode de vie luxueux
permettent au néophyte de l'hameçonnage
de débuter leur carrière assez
facilement nous a fait valoir la
porte-parole du CRTC Patricia vayadao je
ne véritable industrie derrière ça et en
grande partie c'est basé à Montréal donc
c'est des gens de Montréal qui sont
derrière ça donc oui quand on reçoit le
texto qui dit par exemple votre compte
Netflix a été désactivé cliquez ici puis
on clique ça nous amène une page où on
demande de rentrer notre numéro de carte
de crédit nos informations personnelles
donc ça c'est seulement la première
étape on vole les informations bancaires
de la personne ensuite il y a d'autres
gens qui ont différents niveaux de
responsabilité dans cette industrie là
donc la personne va voler un paquet de
numéro de carte de crédit à tête des
dizaines ou de des centaines de
personnes va vendre ce numéro de carte
de crédit-là à d'autres gens ces gens-là
vont l'utiliser pour offrir toute une
gamme de services ça va de acheter des
billets de voyage des billets de
spectacle même acheter de l'épicerie se
faire venir par exemple des objets
électroniques de chez Best Buy tout ça a
acheté avec des cartes de crédit
dans cet écosystème là on a même pas
besoin d'être nous-mêmes pirates et de
voler des numéros de carte de crédit
pour avoir accès à ça on peut tout
simplement rémunérer quelqu'un pour nous
faire des achats avec des numéros de
cartes de crédit
[Musique]
un style de vie qui s'est développé
autour de ça où on voit des gens dans
ses salles de clavardage là ou toute
leur vie quasiment est basée là-dessus
non seulement ils font de l'argent voilà
des numéros de cartes de crédit mais
tous les achats qui font se font avec
des numéros de cartes de crédit volée
comme ça il y avait des gens qui font de
l'argent en offrant des services au
fraudeur donc mettre sur pied des
services des outils pour leur permettre
de faire la fraude on va en parler un
peu plus tard dans l'émission c'est
assez hallucinant
l'étendue de tout ça les experts qui en
a parlé parle vraiment d'une espèce de
chaîne d'approvisionnement frauduleuse à
travers tout ça c'est les mêmes
écosystèmes économiques qu'on verrait
avec des vendeurs des acheteurs des des
grossistes des vendeurs au détail on
parle plus d'un réseau criminel
organique fluide que d'une organisation
criminelle la personne qui va qui est
obligé de rester on peut voir dans les
organisations criminelles dites moi
est-ce qu'à travers tout ça dans cette
communauté de personnes qui s'adonnent à
la fraude il y a un profil type ce qu'on
peut déterminer là si on veut cerner le
type de personne qui fait ça selon ce
qu'on observe selon ce qu'observe les
experts c'est son beaucoup des jeunes
des jeunes parfois qui vivent même dans
le sous-sol dans leurs parents on parle
pas de gens qui ont 65 ans et plus là on
parle de gens plus jeunes et Montréal en
tant que tel comme le disait Jeff c'est
vraiment une plaque tournante de tout ça
parce que ces communautés là
s'organisent de manière régionale donc
pas nécessairement par pays mais par
ville par région et sur télégram quand
on se prennent un peu on se rend compte
que
un très très grand nombre des salles de
clavardage sont montréalaises on parle
du 5 1 4 5 0 il y a du français il y a
du franglais le genre de vocabulaire
qu'utilise des gens chez nous donc ça
permet de dresser un peu un portrait
mais on peut pas être certain à 100% de
ses clients c'est très lucratif il y a
tout un mode de vie à Montréal qui
tourne autour de cette industrie là il y
a un live star excusez moi l'expression
qui vient avec les grands restaurants
les biens de luxe les voitures de luxe
l'alimentation de nos
profils Instagram avec des lieux
exotiques tout ça fait partie d'une
culture qui s'est développée au fil des
ans à Montréal
qui a donné naissance au fait que
Montréal est devenu une plaque tournante
il est victime dans tout ça les
discussions que nous avons eues avec
certaines d'entre elles nous confirment
que les stratagèmes utilisés par les
arnaqueurs fonctionnent est-ce que vous
avez peut-être reçu les textos bizarres
que tout le monde reçoit le dernièrement
tu es ça dit comme vous avez un
remboursement des gros québécois ou
quelque chose de particulier
il dit que mon compte Netflix avait été
désactivé performer la carte c'est
toujours administré qu'avec des
problèmes quand on leur redit est-ce que
vous avez reçu des facturations bizarres
sur votre carte de crédites oui oui mais
je me suis fait rembourser par la banque
ça semblait pas être le gros traumatisme
ça a été quelque chose de relativement
simple de se faire rembourser par la
banque donc ce côté-là disons que ça
veut pas de l'air de les choquer tant
que ça mais il semblait pas vraiment
être conscient du danger que ces données
personnelles là soient entre les mains
de personnes mal intentionnées les gens
vivent pas nécessairement un enfer quand
ça leur arrive mais en bout de ligne
c'est tout le monde qui finit par payer
pour ça mais entre autres avec les taux
d'intérêts plus élevés et les frais de
facturation pour des commandes en ligne
ils finissent par récupérer leur argent
ici ça nous coûte plus cher en raison de
la fraude et tous le prix finalement de
ces fraudes on est tous victimes
dans les salles de clamartage que nous
avons est filtré plusieurs membres
vendent leurs méthodes de blanchiment ou
de fraude et ce n'est pas tout des
sortes de boîtes à outils complètes sont
aussi disponibles pour les Arna en herbe
tout le nécessaire s'y trouve clé en
main pour absorber arnaquer et frauder
les futurs victimes avec une facilité
déconcertante Jeff et Nicolas ont voulu
tester ces trousses d'arnaque sans un
37 du matin Nicolas et moi on s'apprête
à commencer notre carrière d'arnaqueur
donc première étape bien sûr parce que
c'est des services qui sont illégaux il
a fallu qu'on se procure des Bitcoin
bien sûr la crypto monnaie pour pouvoir
acheter ses services là donc on a fait
ça hier ça en général ça peut prendre
une trentaine de minutes une heure pour
qu'on obtienne les Bitcoin et ensuite
fallu qu'on transfère ses Bitcoin là
au service en tant que tel ça aussi ça a
pris une bonne heure donc on va on va
sauter cette étape là aujourd'hui on le
fait mais nous voilà sur la page
d'accueil de service on va mettre notre
nom d'utilisateur et on verra bien comme
étant que ça nous prend donc pour
acheter ce service là ça nous a coûté
180 dollars iOS pour un abonnement d'un
mois c'est une plateforme qui est clé en
main qui permet à n'importe qui sans
avoir aucune expérience en conception de
site web ou même d'expérience
d'arnaquant d'être capable de créer un
site web d'arnaque le super facilement
quelques clics pour notre arnaque on va
faire un faux texto d'Hydro-Québec tu
dis que un remboursement là parce que
vous avez trop payé sur votre dernière
facture donc on va vouloir créer un site
web qui ressemble à la page d'accueil
d'intérêt dans le fond parce qu'on va
leur dire cliquez ici pour transférer
l'argent dans votre compte banque
note site web d'arnaque est en ligne
donc on est rendu le
255 260 dollars canadien et 20 minutes
de notre temps n'importe qui qui a la
volonté d'arnaquer peut utiliser ces
outils là avec un minimum de
connaissances avec deux 300 dollars
canadiens et peut se mettre à arnaquer
des gens en avant midi même pas faisons
l'exercice on voyait un texto à Alexis
on verra comment ces informations là
apparaissent en direct dans le logiciel
bonjour cher client
[Musique]
chers clients vous avez droit à un
remboursement sur votre facture
Hydro-Québec en raison de l'inflation
ok petit cadeau cliquez ici pour
recevoir 150 dollars
je choisis une institution allons-y
identifiant des jardins
pour confirmer votre identité répondez à
la question suivante quel est le nom de
mon premier animal de compagnie c'était
un hamster on va carrément que il est
présentement authentifié dans son compte
ça me dit déjà quelle banque donc déjà
on peut voir déjà le numéro de carte on
a le mot de passe donc MTL 5 1 4 7 9 on
voit qui est sur Safari sur un iPhone à
Montréal donc déjà là donc c'est ça même
si Alexis décidait de se décider alors
c'était trop louche finalement je crois
pas ce site web on a déjà cette
information pour potentiellement faut
dire là-dessus
alors continuez les questions de
sécurité sont complétées il y a un petit
saut ici qui dit sécurité garantie à
100% c'est ce qu'on verra
déjà plus d'infos qui sont rentrés donc
on a les questions de sécurité du compte
ça dès qu'on a ça on peut rentrer dans
toutes sortes de comptes de gens puisque
souvent c'est même question que sont
recyclées vraiment des informations qui
peuvent servir pour un vol d'identité
carrément exactement on s'entend que
quelqu'un qui reçoit un transfert avec
autant d'informations qui lui sont
demandées va peut-être se dire qu'il y a
un problème là-dedans mais c'est pour ça
aussi que justement on peut
personnaliser ça comme on veut pour
avoir les informations qu'on veut
famille Sanchez on dit que le compte
était véritablement vérifié bon la
première partie complétée
ce qui se trame derrière
on a tous ici
les fraudeurs bonjour
non mais sérieusement si vous aviez été
de vrai fraudeur et moi une vraie
victime qu'est-ce que vous auriez pu
faire avec ce que vous avez récolté
comme information au minimum on a un
numéro de ta carte pour le site de ta
banque donc on pourrait aller voir par
exemple combien de d'argent dans ton
compte c'est quoi la balance sur ta
carte de crédit pour voir si tu es
information on pourrait les vendre sur
le marché des cartes de crédit volé ou
des informations bancaires volées
souvent les gens utilisent le même mot
de passe donc on a ton courriel on
pourrait probablement essayer ou moins
tenter d'aller dans ton courriel puis
ben sur d'autres informations qui
pourraient permettre de carrément voler
ton identité sur le web donc une fois
que vous avez ces informations là
quelles sera les prochaines étapes pour
vous là en tant que fraudeur dans ces
salles de clavardage sur télégramme là
il y a carrément des écoles qui montrent
aux gens comment utiliser ces
informations là pour faire toutes sortes
de fraudes ça va de
envoyer de l'argent à quelqu'un pour
acheter des claquito ça peut être aussi
effectuer des achats sur des plateformes
de vente en ligne ça va jusqu'au
carrément le volume d'identité de
quelqu'un pour créer des nouveaux des
nouvelles cartes de crédit ou ouvrir
d'aller chercher des prêts auprès auprès
d'instruction bancaire puis savoir des
choses bien simples comme simplement
faire des transferts intacts pour sortir
de l'argent rapidement donc il y a
différents niveaux de sophistication du
type de fraude qui peuvent arriver par
la suite mais justement ça ouvre
tellement de portes pour ces fraudes il
y en a pour tous les goûts finalement
oui mais pour les fraudes là qui sont
plus sérieuses comme le vol d'identité
ouvrir des nouvelles cartes de crédit ou
aller chercher des prêts ça souvent les
institutions bancaires vont demander une
preuve d'identité avec photo donc on va
demander par exemple envoyer une photo
de votre passeport et votre permis de
conduire l'eau pourrait se dire que les
fraudages butent un problème parce
qu'ils n'ont pas ton passeport ils n'ont
pas ton permis de conduire peut pas
prendre des photos de ça il y a des
outils aussi qui existent pour générer
des fausses preuves d'identité puis on
va te montrer ça maintenant
si ça c'est toute une gamme finalement
de service clientèle qui sont offerts
assez fraudeur là à bon prix donc ce
qu'on va te montrer c'est carrément un
service qui nous permet de fabriquer des
fausses pièces d'identité qu'on peut
utiliser pour authentique identité sur
Internet donc on soit pas une carte en
tant que tel mais c'est une photo d'une
carte qu'on peut utiliser un peu
n'importe où et ça coûte 10 dollars
américains donc ça coûte presque rien
bonne qualité ouais de très bonne
qualité et plusieurs pays disponibles je
pourrais être brésilien sur une plairait
beaucoup bulgaire chinois allons-y pour
le Canada vu que les informations que tu
as entrées ce serait plus cool donc là
on voit ici il y a un exemplaire de quoi
relève le four document au sein de
l'exercice on regardera la photo par
défaut qui est fournie par le site web
mais bon il y aurait des manières
peut-être de générer des visages par
l'intelligence artificielle ou autre et
pour la signature aussi au fait
l'exercice on regardera la signature par
défaut mais on pourrait même
téléversé une photo d'une signature
distincte pour mettre sur ce passeport
et voilà en photo
vous m'avez présenté un éventail assez
impressionnant et varié de possibilités
de fraude avec toutes sortes de trucs
possibles dans quelle mesure c'est ça
s'arrête là dans quelle mesure ça va pas
continuer avec d'autres éléments qui
vont s'ajouter à ce coffre à outils
sincèrement au point où on en est je
pense que presque tous les outils dont
les gens auraient besoin sont déjà là
mais selon ce que nous disent des
experts
le phénomène de la fraude ne fait
qu'augmenter au fil des années de plus
en plus de gens qui sont impliqués
là-dedans et les banques elles prennent
de plus en plus des mesures pour
combattre les ce qu'on appelle des
occulte qu'on veut donc des gens qui
vont prendre le contrôle de compte en
banque et selon ce que nous disait des
experts de Vidocq ce qu'on risque de
voir de plus en plus au fil des ans
c'est c'est juste prendre le contrôle de
compte en banque mais de plus en plus de
vol d'identité pure et simple parce que
justement plus de mesures pour protéger
ses condames en club par exemple
l'authentification à deux facteurs
[Musique]
ces activités frauduleuses observaient
davantage sur le Darknet c'est sur ce
réseau Internet clandestins coopéra un
des plus gros marchés illicite appelé
keridienne Edge cue une enquête de 6
mots Coutu nous a d'ailleurs récemment
permis de comprendre comment le CRTC un
organisme qui n'a aucun lien avec les
forces de l'ordre et parvenu à faire
fermer
au total au cours de la dernière année
le CRTC dit avoir remis 450000 dollars
de pénalité à 6 individus qui menaient
des campagnes d'hameçonnage reste
maintenant à savoir comment les
autorités parviendront ou non à stopper
la fraude qui se trame désormais non pas
sur le Darknet mais plutôt sur le web
conventionnel à travers les plateformes
cryptées
Simon Coutu un collègue journaliste ici
à Radio-Canada David Décarie es-tu
professeur de criminologie ancien
directeur de recherche de la firme flair
bonjour à vous deux bienvenue au
décrypteur comme dans tous une question
de moyens de ressources pour les
autorités qui opère contre ces marchés
lents est-ce qu'on a les moyens
nécessaires à notre portée ici en ce
moment pour agir efficacement sur des
plateformes comme telegram
on commence en fait on va au Québec on a
mis en place une unité de cyber enquête
au cours des dernières années mais c'est
tout récent c'est depuis le début en
fait de la pandémie l'unité est active
au niveau fédéral on ne créé une unité
de coordination de la lutte à
cybercriminalité mais il reste que on
est plus dans la coordination que dans
l'action encore une fois et les actions
mais ça descend en fait aux unités qui
sont dans les provinces et il reste que
pour ces unités là qu'on parle de tout
ce qui est cyber l'enfance va toujours
être mise sur finalement la pornographie
juvénile sur les délits sexuels et je
veux dire c'est un choix qui politique
qui est fait puis on peut penser que
c'est bien on peut penser que c'est mal
mais reste que ces choix qu'on a fait
jusqu'à maintenant c'est protéger les
enfants plutôt que nos portefeuilles
mais c'est aussi qu'il y a des victimes
je veux dire de
réel victimes qui qui est en souffre
alors que les crimes
financier bancaire les gens seront
remboursés souvent
pour ça étant donné que ce sont les
banques qui qui vont éponger les frais
les commerçants aussi parfois finalement
sont tous paraître perdant parce qu'on a
les moyens on aura peut-être les moyens
mais après est-ce que c'est une priorité
mais je pense qu'on est en mesure de se
poser la question moi j'ai parlé à des
policiers qui nous disent que ce n'est
pas la peine la priorité du tout du tout
la fraude pour les autorités canadiennes
entre corps policiers il y en a qui
refait le pas l'information à d'autres
parce qu'ils savent pas plus loin c'est
exactement puis lorsqu'on parle du
Centre canadien antifraude centre anti
fraude Canada en tout cas l'impression
que ça donne auprès de certains
policiers auxquels j'ai parlé c'est
qu'ils vont corriger ils vont récolter
de l'information on va faire des
statistiques mais il y a peu d'action
sur le terrain l'idée c'est que c'est il
faut que ça soit quelque part dissuasif
est-ce que le soleil suffisamment en ce
moment en ce qui concerne le Canada qui
est plus peut-être à l'étranger comme un
maillon faible ce chapitre 1
internationale c'est assez frappant
qu'on regarde des grandes opérations
liées à la cybercriminalité tous les
pays sont là sont même la Roumanie et là
l'Australie est là le seul pays qui est
pas là systématiquement c'est le Canada
et ça ça questionne en fait un peu
comment est-ce que on est intégré dans
ces réseaux internationaux qui de lutte
à la cibac finalité et est-ce que la
dissuasion finalement est peut-être
moins l'autre au Canada parce que
justement on est moins vue au niveau
international ça pourrait être le cas et
le défi demeure tout le temps là de
percer l'anonymat de ces personnes là
dans les réseaux où il sont où ils
opèrent et là encore une fois est-ce que
nos autorités ont l'expertise pour le
faire en ce moment c'est un jeu de la
souris tu sais dans le sens que ça prend
du temps pour débusquer ce type de
criminel là ça prend de la patience pour
attendre que cette personne là va
éventuellement faire une erreur
la question c'est toujours en fait de
savoir versus de prouver donc de savoir
qui est qui sur Internet c'est
relativement facile maintenant si il
faut que je le prouve dans une cour hors
de tout doux raisonnable là on rentre
avec un haut plus haut niveau en fait de
certitude et c'est là où les preuves
deviennent difficiles à accumuler parce
que je peux savoir qu'un ordinateur chez
Simon c'est connecté au DAC web et a
fait de la fraude mais là est-ce que
c'est Simon est-ce que c'est son fils
est-ce que c'est sa femme est-ce que
c'est son voisin qui est venu utiliser
l'ordinateur c'est toutes ces questions
là où on y pense pas nécessairement mais
tout d'un coup ça dit bon plus difficile
qu'on pourrait le penser entrétion un
ordinateur qui s'est branché dans chez
nous c'est pas mal ça c'est moi
ciment la ville merci beaucoup pour cet
entretien très agréable et on va suivre
vos enquêtes et vos travaux respectifs
bien entendu à une prochaine merci
et justement pour en savoir un peu plus
sur les résultats de l'enquête de Simon
Coutu sachez que son article est
disponible tout comme notre dossier sur
les textos frauduleux de Jeff et Nicolas
vous pouvez vous y plonger si disponible
notamment sur notre site Web prenez soin
de vous allez salut